hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
I'm here with Matt Welch we are at the
Philadelphia the Wells Fargo convention
center arena in Philadelphia where the
Democratic National Committee yeah
convention is excuse me it's a little
bit early in Philadelphia but the most
important thing is we are here not with
the Democratic Party nominee but with
the Libertarian Party nominee for
president governor gary johnson a
two-term former republican governor of
New Mexico who is now cracking Gary what
are what are your latest poll numbers
and how do they make you feel I think
the consensus number right now is 10
plus and they make me feel really good
we've got we're launching a campaign 15
by the 15 so if she gets a 15-percent
and if you get to fifteen percent in a
number of national polls you are
included in the do it we are included in
the debates and I saw last week I don't
know if it was true or not but I heard
the projection that there will be more
viewership for the first presidential
debate than the Super Bowl holy count
yeah there's no but so there's no way
that you can get elected president
without being in that game you saw some
caught some of the speech last night
from President Obama he had a great line
in there about how you know we don't
Americans don't look to be ruled which
is great if he had governed that way and
if Democrats would govern that way can
you talk a little bit about the
difference between these sort of as drew
Carey put it at the fundraiser in LA the
kind of daddy state republicanism of
Donald Trump and the mommy stay sort of
Democrat liberalism of Hillary Clinton
to Barack Obama well I've never had
issue with what Barack Obama says I've
always said that it really it's music
it's wonderful listen to it's just that
the reality doesn't match up with the
rhetoric and the Hillary Clinton I think
at the end of the day that it is a mommy
state that it's more government
government will be the solution to all
of our ills and that's going to cost
more money so taxes are going to go up
and she's been the architect of our
foreign policy that really has us
intervening in situations that if we
didn't intervene you know situations
better not necessarily but certainly not
worse that was one of the real
God does junctures I think last night
when they were talking about foreign
policy and all their successes they
didn't mention things like Libya as a
success they didn't talk about the
failure of the past 15 years of
Republican and Democratic foreign policy
or drone strikes and it it was
particularly galling for me and I don't
know if you felt this way when they
would bring out soldier the parents of
slain soldiers who were thanking you
know the the Obama administration and
Hillary Clinton by extension for keeping
their kids safe or doing right by the
world it just seemed to me to be
completely an internal conversation
where they were pretending oh yeah you
know it was almost as if they had to
follow Bush's foreign policy and we're
taking no responsibility for where we
are now what I was really heartened by
is several days ago a poll was done
among active military personnel that had
Johnson at thirty-nine percent Trump at
thirty-one percent Hillary at twenty
percent what do you think explains it
I'd like to think it would have to do
with gosh this is the guy that if if
we're going to be it called into doing
what we signed up for that he will
judiciously use that power that it will
be in defense of this country that it'll
be as a result of being attacked we're
going to be taking your questions so
please type them up and we'll be lend
them in on the facebook comments and we
will get to them shortly on Bernie
Sanders created a unity moment or at
least try to some of the revolutionaries
did not decide to necessarily go along
they've been booing and heckling for a
while as part of his accommodation with
Hillary Clinton here he dropped any
mention in his speech of foreign policy
of legalizing marijuana of the drug war
writ large of surveillance all of these
things can you characterize what Bernie
Sanders is minus those issues well-
though so so first of all happen to
agree with Bernie on all those issues
and have been actively trying to promote
all those issues I just question whether
or not people really believe that
government can achieve income equality
income equality Peter taking from Paul
that's an equation that Peter just loves
and it doesn't work our Bernie Sanders
supporters really looking perhaps though
for opportunity equality and I think the
government can create opportunity
quality having been governor of New
Mexico all of every single piece of
legislation that I viewed was from the
standpoint of is this gonna make things
better so trade right now the TPP um you
know I'm a skeptic when it comes to TPP
but I've just had way too many people
that I care about that have been
advising me namely Cato Institute say
that look may have its faults but it
definitely advances the ball of free
trade so here it is Bill Walden myself
we're the only candidates that are
supporting free trade we're going to be
the only candidates that are going to be
able to stand up and point out that free
trade is the opposite from crony
capitalism and I think that effectively
politically most Americans view crony
capitalism and free trade as a compass
needle that points in the same direction
when in fact they are opposites we have
our first question from Toph Barnes it
off Toph Barnes excuse me I guess it's
topher tov tov or Topher can you
describe how your platform is good for
voters that describe themselves as
democratic or conservative well keep
government out of my pocketbook keep
government out of the bedroom and like
most Americans how about I'm skeptical
when it comes to our military
interventions that they have made the
world less safe not more safe and you
can't make up what has happened in Syria
and Libya not intentional but Obama and
Clinton go in and support the opposition
in both
those countries and in both of those
countries the opposition is allied with
Isis we wipe out the the opposition gets
wiped out the arms go to Isis well not
intentional but it's what happened and
you can't make it up I hear a lot of or
some complaints among conservatives
don't like Trump and consider themselves
to be at least semi libertarian that
you're not trying to woo them enough
that you're not nodding in their
direction what's your response to that
well is that the if Clinton or Trump
either one is elected the polarity
between Democrats and Republicans is
going to even get greater neither side
is going to get along with one another
what if you elected a couple of
libertarians former Republican governors
that served in heavily blue states that
are going to appoint both both
Republicans and Democrats all with
libertarian leanings uh which of those
scenarios has the best chance of
actually succeeding those two governors
in the middle calling out both sides to
come and deal with the issues that we're
facing I think I'm looking at that
objectively you could make the case for
those two former governors can I ask
because with social conservatives and
we're getting two more questions in just
a second a lot of times with social
conservatives the real sticking point is
abortion you believe in a woman's right
to choice and and to have an abortion
talk about your but you consider
yourself a moderate on that issue
explain your position well by moderate
the law of the land is Casey versus
Planned Parenthood and I hate to state
my own views on abortion but they happen
to they happen to mirror the law of the
land exactly in my views after I learned
the law of the land Casey versus Planned
Parenthood a woman has the right to have
an abortion up to the point this is the
Supreme Court of the United States
talking now a woman has the right to an
abortion up to viability of the fetus
and the Supreme Court of the United
States has defined viability of the
fetus
is the ability to sustain the life of
the fetus outside of the womb even if by
artificial means i am not looking to
change the law of the land but i think
in that context women have the right
absolutely have the right do you favor
this this was a huge issue a year and a
half ago and ago and it'll be again what
about a public funding for abortions do
you believe in that or is that a not
important to you well I I do believe in
that i do believe from a libertarian
standpoint that we ought to be able to
pick and choose with regard to our
funding for war and that if we were able
to do that I think public policy would
be a lot more in line with public view
but that's not possible so the problem
is Republicans talk about smaller
government and guess what they offer up
abolishing Planned Parenthood well come
on that doesn't work bill weld and
myself were pledging to submit a
balanced budget within the first 100
days a balanced budget would be a twenty
percent reduction in all of federal
spending that would be a twenty percent
reduction in Planned Parenthood along
with everything else another question
here from Greg see monett do you intend
to stop the drug war via enforcing no
drug laws or seeking decriminalizing
legislation or only or are you only
seeking to legalize marijuana well my
stance on the drug war is the same as it
was in 1999 when I was the highest
elected official in the country to call
for legalizing marijuana I think we are
going to legalize marijuana President of
the United States can d schedule
marijuana as a class-one narcotic
president united states can just d
schedule it completely i'm believing
that obama will do that going out the
door but marijuana is going to remain
states issue just like it was with
alcohol just like there are dry counties
in the united states with regard to
alcohol the same thing will exist when
it comes to marijuana but i think that
when we legalize marijuana
I think California is going to vote to
legalize marijuana in November I see
that as a real tipping point I think
that after California does that I think
20 states will just legislate it
overnight what about what about other
drugs I'm not advocating the
legalization of any other drugs but when
we legalize marijuana this country is
going to come to a quantum leap of
understanding drugs and drug abuse and
it's going to start with looking at
drugs first as a health issue rather
than a criminal justice issue we've got
a Ross Woodward saying when you say you
believe in open borders what exactly do
you mean would you let in any immigrant
or those that have skills that America
needs well I've never used the term open
borders what I've said is that we should
make it as easy as possible to get a
work visa have a moving line coming
across the border so make it easy for
Border Patrol to identify an illegal
crossing that right now is being skewed
by people that are just coming across to
get jobs a work visa should entail a
background check and a social security
card so that applicable taxes get paid
11 million undocumented workers for the
most part has everything to do with the
fact that you can't get across the
border to take jobs that US citizens
don't want and these are just
hard-working people that are looking to
advance their family so you're basically
saying anybody who comes here who passes
a background check meaning they probably
what don't have communicable diseases or
a criminal record they can come here and
try and find work try and find work and
get government out of the business of
quotas they'll either be work or there
won't be work really underreported right
now there are fewer illegal crossings
than ever before this year like 300,000
that's set of many multi-year low and
untold story right now is the fact that
Obama has broken up or sent back 20
the two million heads of household in
this country something that I would not
do as president took press on
immigration for a while because it's
both a flashpoint issue in this election
and it's something that really separates
the rhetoric of the Democrats you know
the Democrats here are saying they're
pro-immigrant will never break up
families but they have Obama is the
biggest supporter in chief in all time
Trump is openly hostile to immigration
and conservative Republicans say he's
weak on immigration your stance on
immigration is the most progressive or
the most liberal what is it about the
idea of immigrants coming here that
scares people so much well let me point
out and you guys probably read it the
Wharton School of Business three days
ago Wall Street Journal came out with an
analysis three scenarios limiting
immigration what effect would that have
on the economy allowing for high-skilled
workers only to come into the country
what effect would that have on the
economy and then a fifty percent
increase in immigration what effect
would that have well there would be a
negative effect on the economy by
restricting immigration there would have
a slightly positive impact by allowing
high-skilled workers there would have a
big positive benefit by allowing for
fifty percent increase in immigration so
what scares people what scares people is
this notion that they are murders and
rapists when in fact they are more
law-abiding than US citizens and I don't
want to diminish in any way illegal
immigrants that have committed horrible
crime I don't want to diminish that at
all but statistically less crime than US
citizens I think people believe that
they are siphoning off the welfare
system when in fact they're contributing
mightily to the economy they're buying
cars they're buying food they're renting
homes they're buying homes they're here
they're participating they're taking
jobs that US citizens don't
want this next question refers to one a
great moment when we last had a facebook
live interview with you and Cleveland it
is and we're doing this the Facebook
lounge by the way it's a really great
setup and thank you for facebook but
Gary did you ever find your phone the
other day I did thank you very much and
I hate to admit this but I did not and
no no I didn't have any security on the
phone I mean that's just crazy so so now
it's on there now if I lose it at least
okay so i can go to verizon i can get a
new one and I won't have lost all my
valuable data talk a little bit one of
the reasons you were looking for oh
sorry one of the reasons you were
looking for your for your iphone was
that you were using it as an example of
why we should be optimistic talk a
little bit about that because you know
the story coming out of the DEA out of
the Republican convention was yeah my
god this is the world worst time ever to
be alive the Democrats here I mean it's
interesting because they're saying no
you know america [ __ ] yeah this is a
great country except we you know where
the most racist country in the world and
we cheat women at every workplace and if
Trump gets elected the Seas will boil
and the skies will fill with sulfur I
mean that was part of the best yesterday
you were pulling at your iPhone as a way
of talking about you know what's good
about the world so what were you trying
to say with that life has never been
better in this country we communicate
better with one another our kids are
smarter than ever the number one law
enforcement tool in the world right now
is this guy right here at which point
during the interview I realized that I
didn't have my phone and I freaked out
and such is life but optimistic about
the future and yes we have issues so put
police shooting police getting shot but
but we are coming to a recognition of
just how we have had our heads in the
sand over discriminant discrimination
we're coming to grips with it quicker
than ever so we will resolve this we
will make life better here at the
convention getting on oculus here which
apparently clock which is in the
facebook lounge they have an oculus rift
oh my gosh look at the ramifications of
that going forward that kids would be
from a virtual reality standpoint be
able to go anywhere in the world and
visit to be able to accept that just
gives rise to cyber terrorism right then
think Isis can be right in your head
there's not the problem it's an
optimistic future oh my gosh and I see
overnight that Facebook blew out their
earnings while for good reason oh my
gosh this is the future and it's
exciting it's optimistic it's better
than any of us because do you worry
about government getting in the way of
technology I mean age shutdown uber they
shut down air being big Facebook in
China and other countries get shut down
or one so i think that the libertarian
position on the internet which is unique
to all other politics is libertarians
don't want to touch the internet leave
it like it is which I view as equal
opportunity for everybody anybody can
stake out a course on the internet and
brand new horizon and before we go to
the next question that Matt will ask
related to this yesterday in an
interview with Bill weld he said that
you would pardon Edward Snowden are you
sticking by that yes I do and I base
that on the fact initially when Edward
Snowden came out and made these
revelations initially my belief was was
that oh my gosh there are going to be
people put in harm's way maybe someone
does get hurt seeing the movie Citizen
for and recognizing how Edward Snowden
went about this releasing the
information to higher powers that would
judiciously release this information
I do view Edward Snowden in the hero cat
and we should be i mean this goes along
with the idea of openness and the
internet and equaling power and speech i
mean we need to get serious about
transparency in our government our
government needs to have no secrets that
i agree and no one is really surprised
by the revelations it's and transparency
believing in transparency question from
Jamie Stein I'm an active duty soldier
who's supporting you my two-part
question is how do you plan to reduce
the defense budget without hurting unit
organization and personnel like benefits
and pay and to what is your plan to
reform the VA well benefits in pay i
think we could probably increase pay at
the end of the day but actually reducing
overall personnel and support of that
personnel yeah that's part of the
equation VA look commitments made to to
military those that have served in the
military that is an obligation that that
there's no compromise whatsoever to
meeting those obligations but how do you
get there well the Pentagon itself says
that we could reduce at 0 back to the VA
like how do you mean everyone says they
want to help the VA and Bernie Sanders
says that you know Congress spent what a
billion dollars in the last year's gonna
be my father two summers ago he's now
close to 97 years old he had you know
World War two so he was in the VA talk
about caring people talk about wonderful
health care apparently the issues are
being able to access that wonderful
health care and that the VA gets stacked
up well to me that's just a simple
issuance of a VA medical card that could
be utilized anywhere the issues both
unbelieving the issues have to do with
access the ability to get the care when
you need so do you give people vouchers
to visit private doctors or what do you
agree about
well back to we I i am i've been really
vocally opposed to the insurance model
when it comes to healthcare believing
that insurance to cover ourselves for
ongoing medical need is just a crazy
notion we would have insurance to cover
ourselves for catastrophic injury and
illness but if we could pay as you go i
think health care would be one fifth the
cost of what it currently is but anyway
you got a denominator endorsed this week
by marvin bush are you getting geared up
for the Neil Bush endorsement well I
hope a lot of people come out and
endorse and I look you don't you don't
immediately come out and endorse you say
hey I'm looking at these guys as an
alternative and there are a lot of
people saying that right now and I
absolutely appreciate those that are in
elected office not being able to cross
that line I very much appreciate those
that have held elective office being
able to cross that line so just saying
I'm going to consider voting for these
guys Johnson well that's a big step and
at this point marvin bush we should
point out is one of george w bush's
brothers and was there another I mean
this marvin there's neal and there's
likely likely outcome that you will have
gotten more votes from the bush family
than Jeb Bush did by the end of Kylie
and a fan of jab I tell you we served
together I thought I was very very
impressed with Joe and it's it's a shame
that that didn't well if Jeb were the
nominee right now I don't know as we
would be getting the nearly the
attention that we're getting Kyle
winters ass as president how would you
handle gun control in the Second
Amendment should there be more
restrictions on the types of guns a
private citizen can purchase I support
the Second Amendment I don't believe
that there should be more restrictions
you know we're talking about assault
weapons right now will assault weapons
is is just a semi-automatic rifle that
encompasses third
million rifles if we want to have a
higher incarceration rate in this
country just make semi-automatic rifles
illegal about half the people that own
those rifles will hand them in and the
other half made up of 99.999% of people
that are law-abiding we're going to make
criminals out of it let me very quickly
the people worry about even though gun
violence and gun crime is a historic
lows people worry about that what do you
do with situations like the Orlando
shooting well how do you prevent those
or limit those well I think unlike other
politicians that always somehow have a
solution to that we all recognize that
anybody who's bent on killing themselves
anyone who's bent on destruction mass
destruction so guy who the truck driving
through a crowd of thousands isn't that
a situation that exists in this country
in ten thousand different places every
single day look these things are going
to happen can we prudently try and
address this well in the case of the
Orlando shooter the FBI interviewed the
guy three times as prison you knighted
States I would love to know what
transpired between the FBI and this guy
and why obviously the system worked up
to the point that it no longer worked
well how might it have gone forward and
potentially that this would not have
happened I don't have those answers but
as president united states i'd certainly
call it meeting right off the bat
question from adrian sinner Dorsch what
do you think about the black lives
matter movement i think it's i think
it's completely relevant i think that we
have had our heads in the sand that
police have a bias against blacks and
that's reflected in the war on drugs
where if you are arrested there's a four
times more likelihood that you will go
to jail and i think it's also reflected
in shooting there's five times more
likelihood if you're black that you'll
be shot by a police officer and that's
just a fact so what are the common
threads department of justice federal
department of justice what are the
common threads best practices you know
that's dallas best practices well police
got shot in Dallas but what what are
they doing in dallas that's right what
are they doing in areas where it's the
worst albuquerque being one of those i
know that the Department of Justice came
in had recommendation in Albuquerque
because of so many shootings and I know
that though that those recommendations
are being followed through on so federal
government oversight just pointing out
the common threads of good and bad and
communicate those when you were in
Cleveland for the Republican convention
you walked around and talked to a lot of
people including when we were talking
with you and had some pretty positive
responses from delegates can you
characterize your interactions with
delegates there and have you walked
around enough here to actually interact
with some Democrats haven't walked
around here at all the what the
observation i will make right off the
top is is the democrats start later and
republican not a bad thing there's no
judgment there just the fact just an
observation but in in Cleveland at least
500 people came up to me to say that
they were going to vote for me and bill
weld a dozen of those had on full Trump
regalia and not one negative comment not
even not even negative inflection like
what are you doing here not even that
it's funny because we're just outside
here we saw Jill Stein walking through
the halls here and she had a lot of
support in the building is especially
among the Bernie Sanders people who are
upset about the way they've been treated
this week but she also got get out of
this building a lot of like vociferous
you know have your own damn convention
what are you doing here the type of
reaction you got nothing not even a hint
of that anywhere in Cleveland among
Republicans leveland and I am trying to
fly low and as is as i was in cleveland
trying to be very
respectful and as I am Here I am very
respectful of the fact that this is the
democrat national convention and that
Hillary is the nominee I just hope to be
able to take them on in in November hey
a lot of people ask this question do you
do you think you take more support from
Democrats or Republicans years ago it
used to always be well you know
libertarians will siphon off Republican
votes and allow Democrats to win but
polls both a couple of years ago when
Robert Sarvis was running for office in
Virginia showed him taking more votes
from the Democrat at the time Terry
McAuliffe in a gubernatorial race and
recent polls show you seeming to take
more support from Hillary is that do you
agree with that and what do you think
explains it I think it's really 5050 and
yeah you're right about more support
currently but not by much so so you
really can't even measure it I do think
that the two-party system is broken that
nothing is being spoiled here with my
run for president it's a neither well
that the two-party duopoly is though
right because I mean you're taking votes
from somebody right well by spoiling it
it's a party that needs spoiling really
this is this is not representative of
most Americans and it's just it's just a
fact Hillary Clinton is speaking tonight
and the focus is going to be on her she
can reintroduce yourself to Americans
after only 40 years in the public eye I
know you've sort of wanted to walk back
you or you know she's a wonderful public
servant that you said on CNN as a
opening characterization but can you
just describe what you think about her
politics for ideas about policy what are
the defects in them what are the what
are the positive attributes if there are
any well if I could walk back the
statement on CNN to describe Hillary
Clinton i would say that Hillary's bill
that she is the establishment is
anything going to change if Hillary's
president yes government's going to try
and
be a bigger part in all of our lives I
believe that I think that that's I mean
the things that she's saying and that's
a generalization but I think it's a
factual generalization so if governments
gonna be a bigger part of our life it's
going to cost us more taxes are going to
go up and neither trump or Clinton want
to address the entitlements neither
trump or Clinton want to address social
security it's a fiscal cliff out there
and if we're gonna continue to put our
heads in the sand over it there will be
a day of reckoning it's going to be ugly
it's going to be inflation that's what's
going to be so what do you do because
one of the you know one of the main
things that you guys both you and
governor weld you're pitching to
Millennials to younger people like
you're in a situation you're in a system
that's not going to be there when you
need it to retire you're paying into a
system for health care for wealthy old
people that is busting the bank and and
everything will be gone by the time you
get there the buffet will be you know
the chafing trays will be rolled up
there will be some crumbs what do you do
to address that in a way that speaks to
young people specifically but us it
doesn't scare the you know the depends
off of older people that there that
there will be a safety net that that
government will be the provider of last
resort and that it I think it is
desirable on the parts of all and that
it does need to be around and right now
there have to be some structural
adjustment structural adjustments
spending has to be decreased so then
does I meaning drawing new lines of
eligibility that's what it amounts to
yeah what do lines of Illinois and I'm
sorry to interrupt but this has been
under my skin since it came out whenever
when and bothered by air or that of
marathons you know what I'm talking okay
but when Bernie Sanders you know said
one of the ways as Matt was talking
about that Hillary Clinton bought him
off was by saying okay we're going to
give free in state college tuition to
kids who live in households that make a
hundred and twenty-five grand a year and
it's like at what point do people making
six figures become charity case
especially for the average in state
college tuition is about eight or nine
Grand I mean is this is this the America
that you would uh you're gonna get
behind I don't think anybody genuinely
believes that things are free somebody
has to pay for them and so we're not
eating out that that course that free
comes with a cost and the ultimate cost
ultimate cost will be the accompanying
inflation that goes along with this and
that's gonna be really ugly that's gonna
be a head jerk question from somebody uh
but I I don't it is though what do you
think of the DNC leaks it had questions
from John Kemnitz shoutout to John
cabinet well no surprise but surprising
and entertaining also do you worry about
the Russian potential Russian angle do I
worry about it you know they were hacked
by Russia well I think that that may be
a reality and I think as president
united states i think that i'd love to
have the president i'd love to have the
government be more transparent about
just what hacking does involve i read an
interesting story the other day that
hacking really on the part of
governments in this case the hacking
works to manipulate in this case the US
political system are you pledging to
keep your personal AOL address and use
it as president the united states am I
pledging to do that would that be that
might be contrary to that might be the
boat that Hillary got into right right
ya know I I really I want to obey the
way we did that one I I didn't have a
chance to argue with you about this when
we talked last time but there's been a
lot of talk with Putin uh and with Trump
about whether or not we should defend
the Baltic States who are members of
NATO and we have Article five duties to
defend them should Russia invade or do
something bad there do you think that we
have those duties and is that a good
idea well that we should
getting elected president united states
i am going to honor all treaties and
obligations economy to do that coming
into office examining those
relationships going forward i think that
those those relationships need to be put
on the table do we really want to go to
war over the baltic states and keep in
mind the USSR broke up because of Russia
Russia's inability to to sustain all
that so you can argue that they're not
as democratic as they could but there
have been reforms made in Russia do we
have to be Russia's a line no but we
certainly don't want to have to put we
certainly don't have to poke them in the
nose either but the regionally if you're
going to re-examine the you know treaty
obligations with the Baltic States that
can only go one direction they want to
be in NATO they absolutely want that
protection well and and that that is
that's the examination that needs to be
that needs to take place and on our side
do we really want to go to nuclear war
over the Baltic States do we really want
to do that what about a shooter is is
the which more likely or what about your
no chance right now that that Russia
involves itself in the Baltic States
they've got enough economic problems
right now that the reality that's one of
the arguments for why they would involve
themselves in the in the Baltics because
to keep people's minds off of the
economic problems at home but well it to
put it slightly differently do you see
reconfiguring NATO's so that it's more
it's more European countries defending
Europe or that they're paying a higher
share well that part of what Donald
Trump is saying and getting US troops
out of NATO I mean in a heartbeat i
think that that can be reestablished but
to have a presence of a hundred thousand
troops in in europe that just from a
common-sense standpoint doesn't make all
that much sense Maggie one won't ask one
more question um yeah let's ask a Chris
Cuomo question as give a give a a
five-word not one word a description of
the Democratic convention
Shin that you've seen so far could be 10
words about okay well just one way I
want to be I want to be respectful III
do so a lot of really caring people here
that believe in a Democrat way of doing
things same on the Republican side look
I'm here making a pitch put me in the
debates and listen to what might
actually be mainstream well thank you a
governor gary johnson Libertarian Party
nominee thank you to facebook live for
allowing us to use this space and nick
gillespie uh I Matt Welch bye bye